money Printing and inflation are not
that great for the average person it
makes it way harder to carry on daily
life and the nearly impossible to
achieve things like home ownership but
despite this the FED won't stop printing
money anytime soon sure they might pull
back for a little until inflation cools
down but sooner or later they'll be
printing money once again because it
protects national interests it boosts
GDP makes the debt burden easier to
handle and most importantly it allows
the government to make up for their
massive deficit as an everyday person we
can complain about this all we want or
we can play the game how they want it we
can invest in stocks real estate
leverage low interest rates and protect
ourselves as much as possible from
inflation or we can do nothing and
remain a part of the middle class that
constantly just keeps getting poorer and
poorer